[Musique]
cette loi permet la mise en place d'un
système de surveillance générale total
en tout lieu partout tout le temps dont
rien ne prouve qu'ils puissent avoir une
efficacité plus grande que ce que nous
connaissons jusqu'à présent dans la
manière d'enquêter et monsieur mélenchon
systématiquement new deal a écrit hier
sur les réseaux sociaux que le préfet
l'allemand organise une provocation en
vue de créer des images systématiquement
jean luc mélenchon prend le parti de
ceux qui viennent détruire la république
casser la manifestation contre la loi
sécurité globale a très rapidement
déraper plusieurs scènes de violence
peu après le départ du cortège de la
porte des lilas fait que la chienlit ça
suffit et que de week-end en week-end on
voit bien ce sont toujours les mêmes
images des commerces qui sont saccagés
des policiers des gendarmes qui sont
sauvagement agressé et des voitures qui
brûlent le gouvernement c'est qu'ils
sont ils ont leur nom ils ont leur
adresse ils savent de qui ils sont les
enfants
ils savent où ils habitent et on les
laisse venir casser le style et sa
marine mais parce que l'errance et les
noms et les parce que les renseignements
français le savent pertinemment 300 à
400 casseurs se regroupent rapidement à
l'avant du cortège des barricades
commence à s'enflammer à l'extrême
gauche on va dire que le gouvernement
est trop dur qu'il ya un maintien de
l'ordre qui est trop violent trop
difficile trop sévère et c est à
l'extrême droite on va dire qu'il ya des
black blocks et c'est scandaleux et oui
bien évidemment gouvernement trahit
contre les black blocks c'est vrai que
les français en ont soupé qu'ils ont à
juste titre le sentiment que emmanuel
macron et le président du désordre que
depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir c'est
le désordre permanent
je propose que l'on créé des brigades
des brigades anti black bloc parce que
il faut réussir sur une longue distance
à observer des caméras de vidéo
protection il faut observer des réseaux
sociaux ici follistes avril si les
sabreurs des policiers fassent des
heures mais vous le savez ça t'aidera
montré du doigt à l'international par
l'onu par une centaine d'organisations
de défense des droits humains
emmanuel mâcon il répond par quoi un
poste de facebook est un exercice de
communication de 2h30 sur une chaîne
médias sur un réseau social dont le
journaliste avait eu à subir les
violences de la semaine dernière quand
on a une couleur de peau qui n'est pas
blanche
on est beaucoup plus contrôlés donc le
seul moyen de bouger c'est de faire ce
qu'on a su faire sur d'autres violences
ou d'autres sujets sensibles
c'est de mettre en place une plate forme
commune pour que les gens puissent
dénoncer de manière très simple unique
et national
il part sur une accusation sans
fondement je le crois sur des
arrestations au faciès que commettrait
les policiers il accepte en utilisant ce
terme de violences policières ce qu'il
contestait quelques minutes avant c'est
à dire en réalité l'idée qu'il
existerait des violences systémique de
la part de la police et peut-être même
un racisme systémique
klein président un peu miroir qui
renvoie à chacun ce qu'il a envie
d'entendre un président de la république
ne peut pas changer de conviction en
fonction de ses intérêts au cador
évidemment que la police elle contrôle
les uns et pas l'autre qui ya combien de
temps que monsieur que monsieur qu un
maquereau est pas allé dans une prison
voix qui occupent les prisons nous mon
et sujet et je crois que ce serait faire
preuve de lâcheté de lâcheté de ne pas
dire que à certains moments dans
certaines situations
oui il ya des discriminations sur la
couleur de peau c'est grave mais ça se
traite
s'il y a des policiers qui sont violents
s'il ya des policiers qui sont racistes
ils doivent répondre de leurs actes et
être puni mais de laisser penser que
toute l'institution peut être
susceptible de se livrer des violences
c'est une faute